I usually have my...
Back to where I come.
So I was jamming.
It's so good!
One more time!
Dude,
I can't speak.
You deprive us of minto jamming.
There's
your minto jamming.
Building with Legos to recreate minto's cafe.
Now watching minto play Kirby's Dream Land.
Yeah, it was so cute!
Chiquita, oh my gosh!
The Legos, I saw.
I saw, I saw.
This intro song for Kirby's Dream Land is a little shorter than I...
Thought it would be.
So we'll give... I'll talk less and we'll get into the game soon.
Alright, you know what?
I could just turn it down a little bit.
Because I was listening to it and I was like, oh...
This is like...
Really short.
But anyway, hello everybody!
Hi!
I hope you're having a good weekend so far.
And...
Um...
Oh yeah, I'm playing Kirby's Dream Land today.
Um, I know it's a short game.
Everybody has told me.
Everybody in the world has said this stream's gonna be like 15 minutes.
Well, what if...
I'm really bad?
Nah, even if it's a short stream, I was like, you know...
I, um...
I did karaoke the other day and then I did a collab yesterday.
So I could...
Okay, 17 minutes.
15 hour stream!
Um, but...
So I was like, you know...
I'll just take it easy.
I'll take it easy here.
How's your throat doing?
After that singing marathon?
Singing marathon?
My throat's good actually.
It was hurting a lot last night.
But I woke up and it was all good.
Cool!
Definitely best place to start as it predates the copy ability.
Yeah, I know that too.
I know that too.
So we don't get any abilities in this game.
But that's okay!
You know me, I like to appreciate things as they evolve.
And where they start and come from, so...
Hmm.
So you know, the game is pretty short.
I can't tell if this is sarcasm or...
Or not.
Oh, really?
I didn't know the game was short.
Oh.
Kirby series was my childhood.
I hope you enjoy the game.
Thank you!
If Kirby ate Minto, what ability would he gain?
Um...
Is it only one?
Does Kirby only ever get one ability?
When he...
When he sucks...
The power.
Apparently wearing my mint shirt.
So cute!
How's he sitting on an ice cream?
Cute!
Guess one.
One?
A bit.
Depends on the game.
Hi, game.
I just wanted to make sure he's a bit too short.
No!
Game is short, but so is Bito.
So you probably won't notice...
Why?
Two of you at the same time have the same idea.
What are you conspiring against me?
But, okay.
One ability.
What would be my greatest ability?
Maybe Moe Moe Beam.
I think that's very powerful, no?
No?
Maybe you end up liking this...
Game?
I should let you know that someone made a Kirby-style Toll game...
Called Sanai's...
Silphid Breeze.
Oh!
I didn't know about that.
Thank you.
Got my desktop...
Desk...
Mat...
Minto!
Just so you know, it's long.
Is it long?
Actually, wait.
I did get that too.
I just never put it on my desk.
Cause I'm waiting on a Koharu.
What?
MintoGamerSubs!
We'll be here Monday!
Wow!
Everything's coming in!
Thank you guys for ordering.
Thank you!
Frosty Trooper Welcome to Membu Ship!
Did you guys see that there's new Membu?
New Membu...
Icons?
Except for...
The one year.
I kept that one.
They're a little new now!
There is one for two years, so...
I have not seen one.
Hmm...
Maybe I will see one...
Eventually...
Hmm...
Okay...
Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you, thanks for the gifter!
Yeah, yeah.
Herbie's Dreamline is short, but if you feel like it, thankfully...
The sequels are on Nintendo Online.
Oh, I won't do them today, but yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Really glad to have found you last year.
One of the...
First VTubers I watched and congratulations...
Watch and congratulations on five years!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Good!
Yeah, so now there...
Yeah, some of you are just a box...
Some of you are ribbons...
Very cute!
Uh, those were made by...
These were made by Crone...
Um...
I was gonna have them...
During my...
Uh...
I was gonna debut them later, but...
I don't know, whatever.
I was being sarcastic when I said the game is short.
It is though.
Just so you know.
Okay.
Really?
I had no idea.
Also, did you guys know that...
Jaeger means hunter?
In German?
I have a question though.
Why is Kirby...
Like a ghost...
On the...
On the cover of this game?
You guys can now flex your knowledge...
Because I am asking.
You know Kirby was supposed to be in Resident Evil 4?
Yeah.
He's a white Kirby.
He's drained of all of his...
Color.
He...
It's...
Don't...
Wait.
Let me guess.
Kirby did not eat enough shrimp.
His color was undecided before the game's release.
Uh...
He was white before pink was canonized.
Yes.
You nailed it.
He's a flamingo.
Kirby's not a flamingo?
No, I think we just established here.
I think we just established that.
He's pink in the Japanese cover?
No way!
The color pink wasn't invented yet.
Oh...
I see...
Friend-shaped game time with...
Friend-shaped Minto.
Am I friend-shaped?
What if Kirby was a ghost though?
That would have been really exciting.
Actually, I really like...
Meta Knight.
So, don't tell me what game he comes out in.
But I really want to meet him.
I'm really looking forward to...
To him.
You're Minto-shaped.
Which is very cool.
Limited colors of OG Game Boy 2.
Yeah, I'm using the...
The Game Boy Color Filter.
Yeah, because I...
You know...
Usually, I'm like...
All about the accuracy.
But I felt it would just look ugly on stream.
So...
That's why we're playing the...
Color...
Game Boy Color version.
I decided that.
That was my executive decision.
When do we watch...
The Kirby anime?
I don't know.
Gosh, I have so much stuff to watch already.
You're gonna love it when he shows up.
He's a...
He's a badass.
I can't wait.
I love his design so much.
I think he's really cool.
So I hope I like him.
I hope he's not like a little punk.
Well, I would still love him if he...
Even if he is a little punk.
I love little punks too.
Yeah, he does have such a great design.
He's so cool.
Not Kirby related, but did you see the Hatsune Miku nonogram game is on?
Steve!
It is!
Since when?
Uh oh.
Are we gonna be doing more nonograms?
Is Meta Knight the ocelot of the Kirby mythos?
I don't know anything.
No s...
Is there spoilers for Kirby?
I don't know.
The 25th it came out.
What?
Hold on.
Hatsune Miku!
Logic Paint!
Wow!
It's...
Fifteen dollars!
Holy moly.
Thank you for always keeping us entertained.
Happy belated anniversary!
Thank you!
Wait...
Oh my gosh.
Rockbiter!
Thank you so much for the welcome.
Super thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah...
Yeah, sorry, I just wanted to chit-chat a bit before we...
Before we started, sorry.
Now I'm watching Hatsune Miku...
Logic Paint S...
Plus...
What are you...
Oh, you can like decorate them?
Wait, this is so...
Oh, and there's like songs!
Oh no...
My channel will get taken down.
Please...
Hatsune...
John Hatsune Miku...
Please don't take down my channel...
For listening to Vocaloid music.
Hmm...
It's a pretty good game.
What the Miku one?
You know, usually I don't play...
Nonograms that...
That punish you...
For making a mistake, you know?
So...
You know...
But...
That was when I first started...
Using...
Playing Nonograms...
I probably could do it now...
Kirby actually has very deep lore...
If you go look...
Isn't Kirby like a god?
Kirby...
Because he's...
Uh...
Sakurai's baby...
So he's...
He is...
God...
Basically...
I'm...
With...
Yeah...
Eldritch being...
Just wanted to say...
Thank you boss...
For playing Kirby's Dream Land...
I first had this game long ago...
When it first came out on the original game board...
And it brought me five memories...
Of course!
You can always count on me playing an old game.
I've never done an Aquasipa before, but if it's anyone that I think deserves the first, maybe you.
Happy late for the anniversary, too.
Thank you for continuing on.
You're all the ups and downs, no matter what.
You don't know you have us behind your back.
Thank you!
Oh, my gosh.
Don't for P.S.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
First ever, too.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Hot dog, indeed.
Gameboy color is a good choice.
Can you imagine having to stare at green and white stuff the whole stream?
P.U.
Who wants to stare at anything green and white?
You are the cutest patootie in the world, shape.
Herbie is like an eldritch beating but filled with friendship energy instead of evil energy.
I mean...
If...
I mean, look at...
Look at... Did you just see him go...
How?
And... And become...
Big and... How?
How?
Just there, there, there, there.
You see?
How?
Um... Also, guys...
Sorry, I just realized...
I'm playing through OBS, so...
Don't... Don't... Don't attack me, okay?
I'm the only one whose chat's delayed.
I don't know.
Chat, are you delayed?
Classic minto gaming.
I'm too lazy to change my monitor.
Especially because sometimes it, like, rearranges my...
Windows.
And that's just a pain in the butt.
But...
I could play it on my tiny monitor.
What if I did that?
That'd be insane.
If I played the whole game on my teeny tiny monitor...
That has...
You know, it's not a...
It's not a chat monitor anymore.
It's been downgraded to clock.
It is now my clock...
Clock-iter.
My clock monitor.
I
can have three wallpapers.
And I think that's kind of nifty.
For...
Decorating purposes.
You are the friendliest ghost since Casper.
What?
I'm not friendly at all.
I'm spooky scary.
Tiny monitor for authenticity.
DDD theme slash...
Is he...
Is King...
Is King Dedede, right?
Is he in this game?
Well...
Don't tell me.
No spoilers.
Let's get started.
Let's play the game.
I've yapped for...
Long enough.
You're a ghost?
Yeah...
Or...
I'm your paralysis demon.
It's spooky scary how friendly you are.
Oh my gosh.
I recently got into watching VTubers, right?
After playing the entire Metal Gear series for the first time.
After discovering your streams and love for MGS, I quickly became a fan!
Love your singing and can't wait to watch you for many years to come.
What the heck?
A camp intro.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
What the heck?
You're already here for years?
You just got into VTubers?
And you're saying you can't wait to watch for years?
Uh oh.
I think someone fell down the hole pretty hard.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you!
I love that people find...
I love...
That's my favorite thing.
So when people find me through Metal Gear.
Because then I can...
I can talk more about...
It gives me an excuse to talk more about Metal Gear.
I can...
Like I have an opportunity.
I'm just like...
Oh!
You found me through Metal Gear?
I'm gonna...
Unleash her freak.
Oh yeah, baby.
Oh yeah.
That was me.
I found you through Metal Gear?
Happy!
Happy, happy, happy!
Can't wait for people to find you after Delta.
I wonder how...
I'm so...
I'm nervous how Delta will go.
Nervously optimistic, but...
MGS Con in less than a month, by the way.
I know!
I know...
I'm...
I will be working MGS Con, so...
No chatter here.
Can you explain...
What...
What Gear Metal?
Sonic Mayhem!
Welcome to Metal Ship!
Thank you!
I pray for the day I wake up paralyzed with mint on...
On...
Hope you have good streams with this pink demon.
Thank you!
Alright, we should get started.
I said that...
Five minutes ago.
Let...
Um...
Okay, gosh.
It's been a second since I've played...
Last game I played...
On my Switch was...
Fantasy Life.
And it's been a minute since I've used a Joy-Con, so...
I have to...
You know when you have to like, reconfigure...
Which one is A and which one is B?
After...
After using like...
My...
I have my other controller...
I might...
I might mess it up a bit.
Guys, guys.
Welcome to Metal Ship.
The Haku!
Witty message.
Hehe.
I laugh at your witty message.
I found you through the cryptic messages of an ancient mountain oracle.
Hope the part about you being a dark omen isn't real.
Oh, Chovec.
I finally started my Metal Gear journey.
Thanks to you!
Just finished MG...
Metal Gear 2.
Metal Gear Solid Waze.
Oh!
You started with the Metal Gear series.
I say series.
Metal Gear...
Games.
Made it home.
You can start now.
Oh my gosh!
Grimble, thank you.
Finally.
I was waiting for you to get home.
Okay, let's start.
Can I turn the music back up?
Start.
Green?
Greens?
Oh my god, he's getting attacked by those...
I know the song!
Wait, I know the song!
Oh, I can suck.
Oh, and I can fly!
Okay.
How do I stop flying?
Kirby?
Oh, that's him.
Oh wait, if so, if I...
If I...
Wait.
Oh damn!
Oh shoot!
Oh no!
Is that bird gonna kill me?
Yeah.
Okay, birds are...
Birds are an obstacle.
Oh dang.
Okay.
Come here!
Come here bird!
Where are you?
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, you're not gonna come anymore?
Ah!
Nevermind!
You hate me?
Come here!
Oh, I can't fly because I'm...
Too fat!
Come in.
Oh!
Which way should we go?
Wait, is this gonna poison me?
Okay, no.
I know these games.
I know you can go in or you can go beyond.
Oh my goodness.
This area is...
Who the hell is that jolly fella?
There's so much...
Why are there so many guys here?
Wait!
Wait, no, no.
Wait.
Let me in.
Whoa!
Okay.
I suck the bombs.
I suck your bombs.
And then I shoot your bomb.
Come here.
What?
Stupid.
Nice.
Oh, shoot.
Oh no!
I wasted my...
Can I eat big things too?
Oh my god!
What?
Oh.
I lost it though.
I can eat everything I want!
This is insane!
What the hell?
This is a black hole.
Wait, what are these?
Do these do anything?
This even sounds like a vacuum though.
Oh!
That enemy was bigger than me!
I know!
Look at him go.
And then I'm gonna eat him.
And then I'm gonna do that.
Wait.
I stripped him.
I'm trying to...
Figure out.
How do I...
How do I float?
Oh, it's up!
Okay, okay.
Thank you.
Go in.
No.
Go inside.
Eat cow.
It's just like real life.
You eat the cow.
These guys are so...
Funny.
Wait.
Wait!
Oh!
I got my health back.
Let's go.
Ice skating.
Oops.
Oh.
That was close.
Haha.
I just like to kill for fun.
I don't even need to go up here, do I?
Nah.
Eat that bird.
You press up a...
Call?
Switches to hard boat.
Nah!
Then why would I go to hard boat my first time playing?
Yeah, I enjoyed all the killing.
No.
Am I going the right way?
Uh...
Kirby?
Kirby, you're trapped.
Oh, everybody's back now.
I might have made a...
I might have messed up.
Oh, come on.
Come on, come on, come on.
Ouch.
What if I go through here?
Wait, what is this...
What is the point of where I'm at?
Wait.
Oh, there's a door right here.
I'm an idiot.
Sorry.
I could not see.
Special music.
Oh my gosh.
Okay,
okay, you hurt me.
You hurt, you hurt.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Wait.
I
died so fast.
What?
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
Yeah!
Give me your apples.
I destroyed the giving tree.
This is literally the story of the giving tree, you guys.
He gives me apples and I kill him.
Let's go.
Stage two!
Ooh!
Castle a lo-lo-lo-lo.
Let a girl...
Let a girl get into the game first.
Let a girl read her chat.
Wait.
Kirby takes fall damage?
There's a mic there.
Kirby a streamer.
What's this do?
That's what I do.
I blow out your eardrums.
Stop, so cute.
Precious!
Oh, whoa, whoa.
I can...
Even I can tell that's dangerous!
Okay, never mind.
You can't kill it.
Oh, my God.
That's just a bomb.
Isn't this place full of such whimsy and joy?
You got bombs...
And ghosts.
It's just a little silly.
It's kind of freaking me out.
Okay.
I think we need more whimsy, if anything.
What the heck is that?
Hi, I'm the...
Oh, my gosh, wait!
I can't suck!
No, no, no, no, no!
Ouch!
Oh, I sucked the wrong way.
I'm speed running.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Wait.
Wait, you were supposed to go in the order!
Okay, there he is.
Let's see.
Okay.
Oh, maybe he does it three times.
Nope.
You know what?
I'm just gonna go inside.
Never mind, I can't do that.
Is this a boss?
No.
Hello?
He's coming to me!
Oh,
okay.
Just kidding.
Sorry, I was... I was all blown up.
Come here!
Did I get him?
I can't even tell if I did or not.
Maybe getting one of...
Oh.
Maybe getting one of the guys...
Oh!
Just jump up the things instead.
Oh, whoops.
Jumping was even an option, I'm not gonna lie.
I forgot it wasn't even an option.
Because I'm just so used to flying now.
Can I suck this up?
No?
Wait, anything down here?
Yeah, I learned how to fly and I forgot how to jump.
So true.
Hey!
Ouch.
I can have...
Wait.
This is kinda fancy.
Nice.
Nice warm meal.
Am I back to normal?
Dang.
Spikey.
Okay.
Please.
There was nothing here.
Forgot the curry was a thing.
How could you forget?
Get out of here.
Let's see.
I want to explore, but...
Okay.
I'm going in here.
Oh, it's this stinking mask.
Yes.
No!
I don't like him.
Okay.
Okay, wrong door, I guess.
I understand.
They're like, hey, stupid.
Wrong place.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Maybe this door.
Okay.
Wrong door number two.
Oh, my bad.
Okay.
I don't think that's a maid.
I think that is a witch.
No?
It's pretty witch-like, I'd say.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Don't pit me, please.
They're cleaning.
With their broomstick.
That is a witch broomstick.
Oh, these guys again.
Okay, okay.
Ow!
I shot it at you!
You son of a bitch!
Oh!
Oh, I get it.
Okay.
I get it.
Guys.
And then you can only jump down and up from here.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
Can you jump here?
You can't.
Okay.
Yeah.
I need to...
Actually!
Jump down!
Okay.
Suck from behind.
I can do that?
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Uh.
It didn't work.
I need to stop pressing up.
Wait.
Where'd your thing go?
Have to be closer to them.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm trying to get a...
Okay.
Here we go.
here we go.
Yeah!
I discovered!
Uh.
Just kidding.
Dang it, I'm so slow.
I'm too slow!
Outsmarted, idiot.
I'm ready to suck.
I was not ready to suck.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
If only I had...
Maybe I just keep it in my mouth.
Until they come back.
Oh, shoot!
Okay.
Wait, can I...
Wait, I'm just holding it in now.
Wait, can you guys...
You guys are like getting in the worst position for me.
Okay.
There we go.
I pressed the wrong button.
My bad.
You guys, if I die...
I'm gonna have to redo everything, aren't I?
I'm gonna die.
I don't wanna die.
Oh, please.
Three more and all...
Drop and sh...
Where did it go?
Wait a second!
Oh...
Where did it go?
I swallowed it?
How?
Oh, that's so icky.
That's so...
How did I eat it?
Wait, did I at least get health for it?
You eat it if you press down.
What?
Okay, well...
Die and learn, I suppose.
Hey!
Stupid?
Alright.
Says me.
I'm the stupid one here.
Sorry.
Really toughie here.
Holy cow.
Okay.
One...
One sibling destroyed!
I'm guessing they're siblings?
Unless they're married, that would be pretty sad.
Oh.
Damnit.
That was unfortunate.
I killed his wife?
Oh, I killed the girlfriend?
Rovers.
Oh, I like a tragic love story.
Look, now he's crying.
Now he's crying as he runs around.
Okay.
Go into a spot... Here we go.
I won't... Wait.
Will I eat it now?
I don't know.
Please come this way.
No!
Oh my gosh.
Come back here, please!
Please!
Please HP and a dream...
I'm so sweaty.
Ah, look at that flapping fish.
I just got a girlfriend!
Which means you just got a girlfriend!
Congrats!
So good!
Oh my gosh!
Great sucking, boss.
Thank you.
I wish I could get more life, but...
Oh yeah, we're eating squid tonight.
What the hell is that?
Merry Happy Birthday!
Eating sushi as I have for the last three years.
Nice.
Quit that!
Freak!
Wait, does this guy do the same thing?
How does he get a selfie?
Oh wait!
I recognize this thing!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Wait, I recognize this guy!
I think?
Oh, shoot.
Let's go.
Oh, okay.
Oh, watch out for that.
Okay, alright.
I'm watching out.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Ouch, ouch!
Please!
I'm just...
Oh my god!
Everything's trying to kill me!
What?
I don't...
Why does everybody hate Kirby?
What did he...
Oh my god.
What did he do?
No, please.
Please, god, no.
Please.
Oh my god.
Please, no.
Use the... Use the scream!
Use the scream!
He ate their families.
You know what?
I believe that.
This is messed up.
There we go.
Okay.
This is an actual hat.
That wasn't my fault.
That wasn't my...
Oh my...
Someone hates me.
For real.
Okay.
Whoa!
Whoa, buddy.
Why does it look like those spikes are gonna kill me?
I didn't get killed by spikes.
I got killed by...
The Moai instead.
The delay makes you stronger.
Yeah!
That's right.
I forgot I was playing through OBS.
Oh, I guess I should've saved...
I should've saved that.
Look at them.
Let them out!
I should've saved that.
Oh my gosh.
I am on my last life.
You know.
Guys, what if I use save states, though?
Whoa.
Is that lab?
Wait.
What is this doing?
Is that a hidden door?
Oh, I thought it was gonna collapse on me.
Okay.
We'll shame you.
What?
You can't get hurt by the spikes!
Oh, no!
Wait, what is this?
Oh, wait, is it...
Okay.
Under the water?
Oh, there we go.
I was too...
I'm too full of air.
Wait, can...
Does Kirby have a...
You know...
Water is safe.
Oh, what up?
Oh my gosh.
Bless, bless.
Yippee!
Is this where I just was?
Oh, yes, I was.
Okay.
I'm gonna become the Joker.
Watch out of spikes.
Watch out for spikes.
Watch out...
Watch out for...
Oh, I forgot that this guy doesn't care...
About...
He's just...
He's just living his own little spiky life.
And I would like to get rid of at least...
Most of this.
There we go.
Alright.
What is that thing?
I like to eat more than I like to...
Just...
Plain destroy, you know?
Hermit crab.
His ass did not want to move.
He was taking his nap, and he was not accepting anything else.
Wait.
Is there anything up here?
What is that?
Uh...
Wait.
I've got one of those before.
No?
I don't remember...
Oh, it made me super powerful, right?
Oh, wait.
Just kidding.
It's a max heal.
Okay, important.
Full heal.
My butt just wants to, like, press up to jump, you know?
Like, and...
Do nothing else.
Hey.
Hey, chill.
Chill.
Oh my god.
What's happening?
Oh, I got a thing.
I don't know...
Oh, the curry!
I forgot about the curry.
Makes me really powerful!
Where did you come from?
The curry!
It's a good...
Lucky day!
The curry, uh...
I was confusing the ca... the curry and the... and the tomato.
I thought I was about to face a boss or something.
I was scared.
I'll take that.
Is this boss time?
Oh, we're going far.
Oh no, I'm stuck!
Just kidding.
Everything is happening so fast.
Kirby, are you okay?
Are you okay, buddy?
Why are there even crabs up here?
Crabs in... in the clouds.
A yam!
Oh, shoot!
Ah, shoot!
Don't touch me!
First time?
First try?
Why?
How many stages are there?
Bubbly clouds...
What
is that?
I think everything in this game is stupid.
Like, positive, not like, you know.
Like, wow, this is a dumb game.
No, like, positive, stupid, cute, you know.
I like the music here.
I hate... these guys...
Oh, come on!
Kill that thing!
Oh, you don't want to shoot your own now, huh?
Yeah, I dare you to shoot.
Shoot to kill.
Oh my god.
Holy...
I'm just...
I'm just fat enough.
Oh, so cute!
Wow, they really explode.
Can I suck them?
No.
I should... keep my distance.
Do not inhale.
Oh, okay.
Oh, devil!
Did I get sick?
No?
They sure are cute.
Are you guys having, like, uh...
What's it called?
Uh...
Flashbacks, right?
Harry Poopins!
No, no, I'm not gonna let you...
Have the...
The chance to even start shooting at me.
What?!
Ouch,
ouch, ouch, ouch!
Okay.
Got his ass?
Whoa!
Sir Kibbles?
Is that his name?
What a cute name.
Okay.
That's enough of you.
This part seems scary.
Alright.
Careful.
Sir Kibbles.
Yeah.
Waddle
do!
Yes!
Waddle do!
I recognize the eye guy.
Why are you not swallowing them to get their powers?
What?
Oh, this is a...
This is a walkway.
Okay.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, you guys said don't...
Okay.
I understand.
I understand now.
They are not cute.
I understand.
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Come here.
You come here.
Yeah.
Hey, chill.
Oh.
Oh, dang it.
Uh...
Oops.
These damn kids not knowing Kirby didn't...
Always have coffee.
Get off my lawn.
Oh.
What are you talking about?
He always had it.
That's what everybody told me.
You
guys told me that just now.
Kirby has always gets the...
Has coffee.
Always has...
Had the ability to get the abilities.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Wait.
I can't figure out your pattern.
I'm stupid.
Please.
Ah, okay.
I figured it out.
Your gamer subs cup and desk mat finally came in and holy neurons activated.
Actually, they've been asking me about my flavor.
So, flavor.
Eventually.
They were asking me about what artist I want to work with.
Oh.
Wow.
He really dodged that.
Good job.
Oops.
I did not think that was gonna happen.
I made a mistake.
What is this?
Okay.
I don't know if I'm going the...
I'm not going the right way.
What does Minto taste like?
What is one of...
Life's great mystery...
I was distracted, sorry.
He goes down.
He goes down again.
And then we go up and...
Wait.
Will he jump again?
Stupid.
Um...
Close.
Okay, nevermind.
Okay.
What was it?
It was over...
Yeah, this guy right here.
Okay.
He does that.
I was in the one spot that he touches.
The yams and curry make you inflate and shoot puffs of air because both foods made the creator sakurai burp a lot.
I can't burp though.
Does curry make you burp?
Okay.
We made it.
No?
Spicy food.
Oh.
I guess that makes sense.
Oh, shh.
Holy.
Holy mini boss.
Oh my god.
I'm not gonna live.
To see the day.
Let me out of here, please.
Please.
He was so bright eyed and sparkly.
I was mistaken.
Okay.
Oh shoot.
I think I have to kill him.
Wait.
My game is lagging.
What is happening?
Did you guys see that?
Wait.
My game was lagging for real?
What was happening?
Why is my game lagging?
Wait.
Wait, actually.
Why is my game lagging?
Alana.
I paused it.
I don't think it's OBS.
It's probably...
What?
You guys say Game Boy limitations, but this is on the Switch.
They emulated the real limitations?
No way.
Seriously?
Why would you do that?
Why?
Okay.
Help me out.
Oh my god.
How is this playable?
Legitimate question.
Is this the beginning...
Of the level?
I think so.
Skill issue.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, he did it!
Chat is lagging a bit tonight.
Sent at 719.
What?
You're confusing me.
You're confusing me!
Stop!
Stop confusing me!
Oh!
I sucked myself into oblivion.
Chat's lagging.
I think that's a skill or show.
Wait, so if I suck too many...
Too many little guys, I fall?
I get too fat?
Why do I keep falling?
Oh, maybe I'm...
Maybe because...
Oh, I have a guy in my mouth.
Okay.
I did...
I did the same thing twice.
Maybe we should just restart this one.
Get your ha...
Minds out of the gutter, everybody.
We're talking Kirby.
We're not talking anything else.
Oh, it's this guy.
Dude...
Oh!
Not you, not you!
No.
Onwards.
Oh, I almost had that guy.
Oh, that was close.
Oh.
I can't remember how...
Oh, I guess...
I did get...
I guess I did get kind of far beforehand.
Before...
The boss.
Dang.
The boss is so tricky though, because he's so...
He's got...
The lag is so hard.
Oh, ouchy.
I didn't realize it was that close.
Just gonna leave you alone.
Oh!
Woo!
What the hell...
I'm losing lives left and right here.
Oh no, I forgot, I forgot, I forgot, I forgot, I forgot, I forgot, I forgot.
Come here, you.
I didn't go as...
According to plan.
Oh, it's this room again.
Okay.
I remember...
We died in here before.
We...
We got this.
We understand this room.
And...
Up in there.
There we go.
I like...
This guy.
Come here.
Oh, please, stop it.
Okay.
Oh,
shoot.
That was just...
Just a little...
Um...
Well, good thing he doesn't know how to turn around.
Stupid.
I'm back!
Wait.
I take a sippy.
This isn't even a boss.
This is like a mid boss, no?
I'm guessing.
Like, this isn't the boss boss?
Okay.
Still tough.
Alright.
What the heck is this guy?
So, I'm guessing I have to get him.
Why is Kirby running?
Kirby.
Reposed, buddy.
Woah!
Hold on.
I'm taking a...
A cough drop.
Appreciation to Badaku!
Pew!
Look at him, girl.
He's got them sick moves.
Okay.
I'm guessing I have to suck up the other guy and hit him with that.
Cause my...
My other moves did not do anything.
So...
I'm gonna try and not fly.
Oh, ouch.
Ouch!
Oh!
Oh, I missed.
Ouch!
Catch him!
He's just...
Come here.
You guys, it's going so poorly!
There's nowhere safe!
Please!
And...
Jump...
Shoot!
Oh!
I'm holding my Mega Man.
Come here!
I got him once!
Yes!
Ah!
Articles on the screen!
Oh, I got his ass!
Oh, ouch.
He got my ass, too.
Mutual ass beating.
Come here, come here.
Just one more!
Yeah!
Uh-oh.
Wait, what's the yam?
Why do we need the yam?
Oh, gosh.
I'm in space?
I think I missed my opportunity.
Sorry, I thought it was going to be a fight like before.
Pew, pew!
Let's just make ourselves a nice little pathway.
Oh, I can get some water!
Oh my gosh, please!
I'm so thirsty!
Wait, what else is in here?
More water!
There we go.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Yeah, I'm playing Minecraft right now.
Does Kirby fit in one by one?
Run!
Nice.
Okay.
I guess he does.
He's a teeny tiny little guy.
I'm so thirsty!
Imagine getting that only just to waste it.
I was...
Okay, but I want that other water too.
This one is the...
Maybe I should come from the other side.
Oops.
I'm gonna go in from the other side.
Wait, I don't need...
Oh, is it just a...
Oh, it's the full heal.
Okay, never mind.
Just kidding.
We don't need it.
I could get the full heal now if I wanted to.
You know what?
Yeah.
I'm gonna get it.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Am I just safe in here?
Yeah.
We're playing it real safe.
I don't trust myself.
That's why.
Okay, here we go.
Whee!
Oh, all these guys are back.
That's right.
Oh, shoot.
I knew that was gonna happen.
That's the sad part.
I knew it was gonna happen.
So, I...
That's why I was like, oh, these guys are back.
Oh, that's right.
It's this thing.
Wait, do these...
I'm guessing these hurt me.
Please!
Okay.
Oh, maybe they don't.
Just kidding.
Like, it's one of those types of games, you know?
Where you're just...
Maybe I'm so used to...
Oh, what's that game?
Not...
Nas don't know Atlantis.
I'm so used to that.
Where it's like, any...
Any teeny tiny thing touches you and you're just...
What
it is!
Everything's so sparkly!
Yep!
I'll...
Wait, did I kill him?
Or did he touch me?
Actually, I'm not sure.
Whoa!
Golly!
Let Minto get to the Kirby lore.
Is there lore in this game?
I feel like there wouldn't be, you know?
I'm just gonna keep going up.
I rescued that yesterday.
You're welcome.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait.
What a frame.
Guys, if I die here, I die in real life.
Is this the boss boss?
It's gonna be so over.
Look at him go.
You missed the secret room.
Oh, gosh.
The streamer missed a room on a game that she's never played before.
Gosh, I hate when streamers miss the secret room on a game they've never played before.
Just...
Yeah, I know I'm already dead.
And that's the problem!
That's the problem!
We'll see how toughy this is if I want to save state.
Okay.
Why are you puffy?
Oh.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Suddenly it's Toho.
Oh, shoot!
Oh.
You also shoot things.
Okay.
Yes!
I got him!
I got his ass.
Oh, just kidding.
I'm eating your bullets.
Give me your guy.
Oh, shoot!
Dang him!
Oh!
The lag, oh the lag is...
killer.
Please release another man.
Easy.
I would did it, wait why was that actually so easy?
Oh,
lagi.
He didn't do the...
If he had just swooped one more time I would of been so dead.
Oh my god.
Maladity!
If he had swooped one more time, I would have been donezo.
Why is he...
When his face is like this, it's so funny.
Oh, wait, no, no, no.
I wanna go back.
Wait, no, no, send me back!
Send me home!
Wait, uh...
Is it a boss rush?
Oh, I just killed that guy.
Wait, wait?
Where's the boss?
What?
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh, shoot!
Oh, I forgot to jump, my bad.
Ah!
I'm gonna die to this guy, I'm gonna die.
Please, send me a man.
I
need...
I need a hero!
Oh, shoot, I thought it was it.
Okay.
That's one bash down.
Oh, these guys!
I have one health.
D...
Yeah, it's so over.
One HP for four bosses.
And I'm guessing I have to fight him, too, no?
Um,
I thought this was, uh...
Nintendo.
What in the Capcom is this?
The boss rush?
One HP in a dreamland!
I forgot about this area.
Cows and everything.
Look at you guys.
The birds!
Yeah, I wish they would give me HP.
That would be really...
Oh.
That would be something, huh?
Oh, this guy.
Jolly lad.
Over here.
Oh, I have to destroy them, I guess.
Oh my gosh.
So...
Kirby needs better grip on his shoes?
Kirby needs a bit better grip on his shoes.
I'm just gonna say.
I'm just gonna tell him now.
Good thing we only fought this one guy, right?
What should we do?
Maybe we do the harder ones first.
Okay, so let's go with this one first.
I heard that grunt from across the room.
Yeah, we're blaming his shoes.
Yeah, why wouldn't we?
Why is this...
This area is my final boss.
Make it to land.
Just make it to land.
Don't...
Okay.
What was this boss, anyway?
Kirby shoes?
The tree.
Yeah, I'll remember it.
I'll remember it.
Like, I remember...
I don't remember what he did.
Oh, no!
He can actually hit me now!
Oh, that's right.
That's right.
I remember now.
Oh, shoot!
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, come on!
Okay.
Get me out of here.
Um...
Let's see.
Oh, this one was the shmup one.
Let's just go in.
Let's just do this one.
I won't have you.
I'm guessing...
Down into the pits?
Okay.
I love the way this guy itches at you.
What?
This is so...
No!
Oh, no, you guys.
I'm gonna touch the spikes!
I'm gonna touch the spike!
This is so evil!
Oh!
Wait, this is actually so mean.
What is...
Why am I playing Flappy Bird all the time...
All the sudden?
Flappy Curb?
Oh my gosh!
Merflazer!
Have you been around?
I feel like I haven't seen anyone forever!
What the hell?
Okay.
Just pace it out.
Oh gosh.
Spinabit, yeah!
Wow!
Thanks for coming back!
Okay.
I did it.
Oh.
He's flexing on me.
Okay.
Alright, we made it!
Oh!
Thank Bunker.
So good to publish.
I like you.
Okay.
Ah!
There we go.
Okay.
I guess I could've...
Gone down, you know?
Whatever.
The Yam!
Here we go!
Oh, shoot!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
I don't...
I don't know his pattern.
I just...
I just literally stayed on him the entire time there.
Hold on, guys.
I gotta take a...
I have one last syrup.
Give me a second to eat it.
My throat's not hurting.
It's just really, like...
Phlegmy today.
I don't know why.
No, I don't think I'm getting sick.
Hmm.
Yeah, probably too much ectoplasm.
I think I'm gonna get more...
Drink in a second.
Yeah.
The tiniest music loop ever.
I guess they don't expect you to stay on this menu for...
For this page...
Page?
This...
Screen!
There we go.
Glad to see this game still looking great and bringing you joy.
Thank you!
I'm having fun.
Sorry.
Oh, I missed him.
Oh, that's right.
Here.
I've already lost...
Three health.
The pain!
The...
I wish the yam would give me health.
That thing took three damage.
That's insane.
Alright, when he...
I just gotta remember he's gonna rev up and then go...
Okay.
Oh, oh.
I need to pay attention.
I'm not at all, actually.
Oh, ouchy, ouchy.
Oh!
Oh my god.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh!
That yam is called the mint leaf?
Wait, no kidding?
Wait.
Is...
Wait, is there a type of yam called the mint leaf?
The run lives on!
Oh my god.
I don't know.
What should we do next?
I'm gonna die for sure at the next one.
Oh, well.
Okay.
What if I do...
The lovers...
And then we do the eyeball.
Oh, but I need...
Oh gosh.
Wait, sorry.
I'm gonna pause it.
I only have two lives left.
I have to save one for...
For ddd2.
JP is yam.
En is mint.
Is it cause I speak English?
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna go get some more tea real quick.
I'll be right back.
Sorry.
I didn't expect my voice to get...
Wanna save state it?
I might.
We'll see how I'm feeling.
Because I don't mind doing all of them again.
They don't take that long, you know.
Okay, I'll be right back.
Sorry, I left you in the...
In the silence with your own thoughts.
I left you in the silence.
She's back.
Welcome back, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
It was lonely.
Was it...
Was it lonely without me?
Let's just go for it.
Alright.
Oh, I forgot I have to...
I hate that I have to go through the stage first.
Wait, so I'm guessing I go up.
Oh, no, please.
That is a witch.
That's no maid.
I'm scared of the mask.
I don't like it.
It's like a creepy no mask.
It's muddy stuff.
Exactly.
What are you supposed to do with the masks?
Where are they going?
She's going crazy.
Just avoid it.
I think I can go over it.
You cannot go over it.
Wait, I don't even see this sleepy thing right here.
What the hell is this?
Woo!
Are you winning, men?
I'm not losing.
Just a little bit, actually.
Oh, it's me!
I found me!
Okay.
Hey!
I like spicy men.
Bubba is an herb and not a spice.
Explain.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Okay.
Did you see that juke?
That was a gamer move if I've ever seen one.
I need to learn how to jump instead of...
Okay.
Get it.
Nice.
Damn, I missed him.
I missed him.
Ah.
Oh!
Oh my god, I did get him.
Nice.
I was afraid that my input...
My button...
Sorry.
I didn't mean to have such a dramatic gasp.
Stop coming over...
Wait, I guess I could've...
Nice!
Okay, one...
One guy down.
Okay.
I like to just focus on...
Like, a couple of them, you know?
Nice.
Got your ass.
I like to get it from behind.
Yeah.
It stresses me out!
Stop running at me!
Okay.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
Okay, we'll just wait for them to come back up here.
And then...
Oh, wait.
Oh, but they'll be...
Oh.
Wait.
Come back to the top, please!
Yeah, it'll hit the block if I do it, so...
What did I phrase?
What did I say?
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Nice!
Okay!
Oh, it's the eyeball though.
You guys, it's the eyeball!
Maybe I should've done this one first.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where did I go from here?
Oh, I guess...
Oh, please leave me alone.
Freak.
Leave me alone.
Everybody.
Okay.
Don't touch me.
Don't talk to me.
I'm anti-social.
I...
Don't want to be...
Involved in any...
Affairs.
I don't wanna talk.
I don't wanna...
Look in your direction.
Okay, nice.
That was painless.
Barely.
Never speak to me or my Kirby again.
Alright.
Those Gordos are insta-kill, by the way.
What's a Gordo?
I don't know the name of the enemies.
The spiky balls.
Oh.
I did hit that guy before.
Yeah, and I did die.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I'm nervous.
Let's just go.
It's not looking hot, guys.
It's not looking so hot.
Oh.
Ouch.
How do I avoid you?
When you do that?
Oh, I'm losing lives like crazy.
Oh, my gosh.
Crouch in the corner.
If I can get to the corner.
Okay.
I like my, my little plan here.
You just stick to the right.
Stick to the right, baby.
And then you just drop right on his head and everybody dies.
Oh, guys.
Easy peasy.
My insti...
I know I shouldn't jump over him, but my instinct wants me to.
You know what I mean?
Me getting in the corner.
I'm preemptive.
Oh.
That hurts.
Just kidding.
Sorry.
I'm angry.
Angry.
Sorry.
Please.
Please come in.
I wouldn't say clean.
But...
An attempt was made.
Okay, how do I kill this...
Oh, my God.
Ouch.
Wait.
I'm deciding.
I'm deciding if I wanna...
If I wanna...
Go back in time or not.
Oh, I did...
Oh, I didn't create one.
Wait, it saved?
Oh, my gosh.
You're right.
Oh, the game was so kind.
Oh, my gosh.
The game is kind.
Okay.
I saw someone say I swallow the stars or...
Oh.
Ouch.
Wait.
Are there stars?
Oh.
Ouch.
Wait.
Oh.
He just did the same thing after doing everybody else.
Ow.
Stop.
Holy cow.
How are you supposed to swallow the stars?
This guy is...
Insano style.
Leave me alone.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
He is really good at cornering you, though.
Oh, shoot.
Ouch.
Okay.
I
was too preemptive.
I don't know why I thought he would stop.
Ow.
Oops.
Okay.
I understand now.
I understand.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Get me out of here.
Dude.
Come here.
I like when he does that, you know.
It's nice and easy.
Yeah, stupid.
Ha-ha.
Oh.
Dang, I could've...
Okay.
Oh, dang it.
How am I supposed to be in front of him during that?
Yeah, the pixel art is so good, right?
Oh, shoot.
Ah, shoot.
Can you jump?
Stop.
This guy is so clumsy.
He's so clumsy.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, ow!
Oh, ah!
I almost had it.
Oh, shoot.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I can't...
I can't time it very well.
Oh, ew!
Okay, here we go.
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
Nice.
I...
I barely...
dented him, though.
I barely dented him.
Beep.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, yeah.
Keep down that.
Keep doing that, keep doing that.
Keep doin' that.
Yeah, yeah, keep doin' that.
No way, that's... crazy.
I got tapped by his... by his mallet.
Oh, the backswing, yeah.
Oh, it was too far away!
Oh, that sucks.
That would've been so good.
Please.
Nice.
I don't know how to time it, so I just avoid it.
I'm sorry.
I don't know how to time it.
I don't know how to time it!
Slow and steady.
Slow and steady!
Oh, shoot.
No, I didn't go up high enough.
I was so close!
Let me try... Maybe I can try and figure out the mallet situation.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
Oh, my god.
Oh!
Oh, I'm dying.
I lost two health.
This is so unfair.
Cause I, like, jump to... to avoid it, but...
Maybe if I, like, just jump instead of...
Okay, run.
Aha!
Hi!
Okay.
Oh, that was not good.
That was it.
That was the op... I got cornered.
Oh!
Wait, this is not the run!
Wait, this is so not the run.
This is so not the run.
Ouch!
Ow!
I'm a combo!
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, my god.
Wait.
Uh, sorry.
I heard something.
I thought it was my cat.
Sorry.
Can you, like...
Oh, shoot!
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, dang it.
That was the perfect opportunity, no?
Oh, I'm gonna die here.
Ouch.
Not die.
I mean...
You know.
I didn't want to be cornered there.
Ouch!
I...
Oh, it was too far.
Oh, my gosh.
That was so close.
I almost touched him.
I almost touched him for real.
Wait.
Okay.
King Dedede!
Chill out, please!
Okay.
Nice to...
He just tripped over nothing.
I'm so stupid.
He tripped over...
Dummy.
Oh, that was me.
Nice to...
My soup.
I keep going up too high.
I don't mean to.
Is this it?
That's something you would do.
Shut up.
He says, I'm stealing your house and all your food!
Now try hard mode.
I think I'm good.
Kirby is hungry.
He's going down.
That was so silly.
Bobby!
Thanks, Bobby.
Special thanks, Cypher.
Cypher...
Good job, Green Shizu Girl!
Who's Bubby?
Ah, and so many players!
Kirby's Dream Land, presented by...
Howl?
I'm bored, sorry.
And Nintendo.
Thank you for playing.
Yeah!
Oh, oh, after- after credits scene.
It's... oh!
Oh, give me the turnip!
Oh, bye-bye!
So cute!
Give me the banana, please!
Press A.
I thought that was... oh, King Doody.
Press up A and select on the title screen to start a new adventure.
G... guck?
Guck, everybody!
Ah, it's a little temper tantrum.
I love how it shows the... the... the Game Boy.
Thank you, Eduardo!
Haven't played this one, so kinda how it... so... kinda how it... wait.
Well done, and thanks for the playthrough!
It was fun to watch Kirby mercil- mercilessly slaughter the kingdom, murder the king, and steal his house.
Haven't played this one, so it kinda seems without a context.
Right!
Oh, it said good luck!
I thought it said guck!
Is that it?
How do I get to the title screen?
Hey, you're pretty good!
I beat another... gaming classic.
Another... another one in my belt.
No save states needed.
Reset?
How do you reset?
Logan, thank you so much for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Z-L-Z-R.
Oh!
Oh, like... okay, okay.
What was it?
Select...
Up...
What was it?
I'm just curious.
Up, A, select.
Extra game!
I'm just curious.
I love green greens.
What a... what a name.
Oh!
Wow, they're fast!
Holy moly, they're fast!
I just ate a chicken.
Wait, wait.
Why is it, like, lagging even more?
You guys notice that?
Another W for retro VTuber means...
Oh my gosh, even the cake is evil!
Extra game playthrough win.
I don't...
Wait, I didn't go in here last time.
Are you kidding me?
There was health in here the whole time and I just missed it?
Oh my god, chicken.
Oh my god.
Jolly.
Ow!
Oh, he dive-bombed me!
I love riding the star.
That might be my favorite part.
Oh my god.
Holy- Holy...
He dive-bombed me!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
Oh my god.
I killed him.
No I didn't kill him.
Oh my god.
He's going to kill me.
They're eating her.
And then they're going to eat me.
Oh my god.
This is when you will learn, kid.
If you... Oh, I just... Wait, it wasn't a cake at all.
It's a little worm.
I thought worms are supposed to be in apples, you freak.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm not going to play the whole game again.
I'm just... I'm just curious how things are in hard mode, you know?
Oh my gosh.
Man.
Oh my god.
Oh, I just barely missed that.
Yeah.
Leave me alone.
Jolly.
Oh my gosh.
It's lagging so badly.
Like, how are you supposed to...
You know?
Oh my gosh.
How are you supposed to play when it lags so bad?
I just noticed my health.
How did I get that bad?
Congratulations on beating...
Minty's Dream Land.
It's an awesome game with...
Other goofy characters like...
...Gordos, and Blombos, and Fantos, and whatnot.
I'm excited to see what other classic game you'll be next.
Thank you!
A chicken.
Oh, I kept getting hit by the chicken.
That guy was supposed to be my dinner.
What is he doing up there anyway?
Oh, he's doing a little circle dance.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, die chicken.
Oh, my gosh.
How am I actually so good at this game?
Said no one ever.
Okay, let's see if I can beat the first boss.
Oh, my God.
What the hell?
Ouch!
Ah!
Congrats on complaining.
You're curvy ramparts.
I mean, though, you know about Gimmick.
Mr. Gimmick in the West.
It's like...
It's cute like Kirby.
I think it would be fun to see him play one day.
Things are always bright in your days.
Thank you, Wobbling.
I didn't know about it.
But I'll look into it.
This is diabolical.
This is so evil.
Okay, we'll just go until I run out of lives, right?
Let's just keep...
Let's just...
We'll keep trying until I run out of lives.
That's so evil.
Actually...
And the...
And the apples hurt too.
Everything hurts.
Oh, my God.
What are you...
What are you supposed to do?
Attention
at all.
Because I'm laughing so hard.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
No way, I didn't get him because of the... OK... Oh... I got him, I got him, I got his ass.
I got his ass.
Wait, is this the run?
Wait, please.
Wait, no, no, no, it's not the run.
I lied, I lied.
I lied, I lied, I lied.
I lied.
I
hit it.
I got, I got hidden.
Oh, wait, I have one more life?
OK, let's go.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
No, that was supposed to hit you.
No, you were the chosen one.
Okay, nice.
Ouch, ouch.
Never mind, not nice.
You were the chosen one.
Okay, once you kind of... Ouch, I need to turn around.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I got close, though.
I got pretty close.
He had two hits left.
You did good, Min.
Thank you.
That was insanity.
Got a good handle of the pattern.
If he hadn't blown down at that last one, you know.
I think I would have had it.
But this was so fun.
I hope you guys look forward to more Kirby games in the future with me.
And, you know, I just... I do like playing retro games.
They're... they're challenging.
And I like that they help me...
...grow.
You know?
Thank you, love.
Thank you.
Thank you, Tri-Pertsaurus.
Yahoo.
Yeah, I want to go through more of these.
So, you know.
I just wanted to start Kirby at the very beginning.
Especially because I haven't played any of them before.
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yay!
I don't know when I'll play the next one.
I'm not... It's probably not going to be like a weekly thing.
It'll probably just be like whenever I feel like...
Playing Kirby.
I'll play Kirby.
Kind of deal, Leo.
But we'll play more in the future.
We shall, we shall.
Enjoy seeing all the differences.
Yeah, right.
Wait, so...
Does Mega Man win?
One day.
Congrats on beating your first Kirby.
Kirby Superstar is my favorite.
It has great co-op.
Hope you have fun with it when you get there.
Thank you!
Thank you for the fun stream.
Thank you, thank you.
May I recommend the OG Ghostbusters from the Super Nintendo?
Ghostbusters.
Thanks for today and happy late 5th anniversary.
Thank you, Mario Playser.
Thank you.
Welcome back.
Glad you had fun.
Next game is the girl.
Let's go.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Thank you.
Thanks, Makini.
Thank you, Vita.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ankylosaurus.
Ankylosaurus.
I always said Ankylosaurus as a kid.
So I have to stop myself from saying that.
But that's actually my favorite dinosaur.
Thanks for showing us how to beat the game like a pro.
Thank you.
I love retro gaming, VTubers.
Welcome to the club.
I dabble, I dabble.
Kirby Superstar rules.
Get power up.
We stand it.
Yeah, when does Kirby get the powers up?
Powered up.
Hello, I'm Puyo.
Thanks for the stream.
Extra phlegm is probably from your throat healing.
Make sure to hydrate and do healthy things.
Like not scream too much at any...
Well, my throat doesn't hurt even though I scream, so...
Oh, next game?
So, soup?
Oh, let's go.
I will once again recommend you try Sly Cooper.
I never played that, Salken.
Wait, Salken!
What does your girlfriend think about your tattoo?
I'm just curious.
Is she watching me right now?
Is she watching right now?
I want to know too.
Is she a wisp?
Yeah, our girlfriend.
Sorry, bye-bye.
Our girlfriend.
I'll fund heart, gold, soul, silver for a stream.
Oh my gosh, I would love to do a Pokemon run where I...
Where I...
I like doing runs where I use only Gengar.
I would love to do something like that.
Pirate, thank you!
Fukuro, thank you!
Bodying, dooday.
It's not a Nuzlocke.
It's like, uh...
One...
One Pokemon only.
But like, not just one.
Like, only...
Like, I'll have six Gengars.
You know what I mean?
She's sleeping, but she thinks the tattoo is cute.
She watches Chibidoki, though.
So no wisp yet.
Get her in!
She thinks the tattoo is cute, you guys.
There's hope!
Oh my god!
You can tattoo another girl's name on your body.
And you can still date somebody.
That's insane!
I'm so happy for you.
Kirby's Adventure on NES.
Where he gets the powers.
In the second Game Boy game, Kirby's Dream Land 2.
Has powers also.
Take it so long!
Thank you for the fucking thing!
Retro streams are rare.
This is really fun.
Really?
Sorry, I'm not good at them.
You know, I feel like people expect, like, you know...
Because it's a retro game.
You would expect a person to either grow up...
With the game or something like that.
I never played these.
So for me...
It's all...
It's all new territory.
Now...
Watching...
With my wife!
Hi, wife!
Hi!
Hello!
I love the Kirby's Dream.
So I'd...
I'd be so down for a Pokemon's Dream.
Okay, we will do Pokemon in the future then.
I love...
I can play Pokemon for a really long time, you guys.
So...
If I play Pokemon...
Expect, like...
Crazy long stream.
Expect crazy long stream.
I would...
I would pretend that I was going to the bathroom...
And I would sit on the toilet...
For, like...
Hours...
When I was a wee wisp.
And...
My mom would be like...
Are you...
Are you okay in there?
I'd be like...
My stomach hurts so bad!
Playing Pokemon.
So, yeah.
When Sanic...
Oh, you guys missed when I first played...
I played Sanic before I went to heaven.
My VOD is...
Gone.
The 15 hours of Minto Pokemon playthrough...
Is what we need in life.
Yeah, right?
It's just so...
I don't know.
It's just so easy to play.
It's so relaxing for me.
I don't know.
Hold on.
Which one did I play?
I think it was...
I think I played Sonic 1 and 2.
Any OG Wisps, remember?
Any OG Wisps...
Come out of the woodworks and remember?
Let me see.
Live.
Oh my gosh.
I have 400.
It's like...
You are on 60 out of 442.
I mean, I could always play them again.
I'm not saying that I won't.
I'm just teasing you.
Sonic 3 in the future.
Maybe...
There's so many games you gotta play.
Okay.
Oh!
Sonic!
I see Sonic 2.
So I definitely did Sonic 1.
Where is it though?
Sonic 2.
I played...
March 15th, 2021.
Wow!
So long ago.
Pokemon in the toilet is something all gamers do.
It's true.
Oh my gosh.
I wasn't thinking about getting that Z Flip phone.
The new Samsung.
Because I just thought it was like...
Big and kind of unnecessary.
Like, you know?
It's just kind of...
It's just kind of big.
And then it has a screen on the front too.
I thought it was too much.
And then I saw someone put a...
Like a...
A DS emulator on it.
And I was like...
Oh!
Wait.
That's kind of cool.
Wait!
Wait.
It kind of looks awesome.
It's pretty big unfolded.
Yeah, right?
It's huge.
I don't need like a tablet in my pocket.
But then I saw the 3D...
Or the...
The DS.
And I was like...
Wait.
It's kind of cool.
Am I like the Sonic Adventure games?
Live and learn!
Actually, I'm only seeing Sonic 2.
Did I not play Sonic 1?
Am I a poser?
Yeah.
It could be because...
Well...
When I was a wee wisp...
I only had Sonic 2.
So that could be why I played it.
For my own nostalgia.
I want to play the one where that...
Girl dies and everyone cheers.
Yeah, I don't see the other Sonic.
I think I only did Sonic 2.
Wait.
Yeah, maybe I only did Sonic 2.
That's Adventure 2.
What's wrong with you?
I want to know why they cheer.
I want to know why.
I'm just curious.
Play Sonic 06.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I actually want to.
I want to experience Peek.
My spooky Oshii.
I think everyone found her annoying.
No.
That's so sad.
Is it one of those situations where like...
I don't know.
There's some characters that people found annoying in the past.
And then they...
And then nowadays people actually appreciate them.
Playing through retro games?
Would you be interested in playing Star Fox?
Oh, yeah.
I've never played that either.
I didn't have a...
I only had a Game Boy.
Well, no.
Okay.
Hold on.
At Game Boy, I got...
I got...
I received Sega Nomad from my older sister.
So that was a hand-me-down.
And then I had a PlayStation.
But I didn't have a...
N64.
So I never got to play any of...
Like, that's why I never got to play Smash.
Anything like that.
Like, I never...
I never had any of those.
I didn't have a GameCube.
For some reason, Game Boy was the only, like...
Nintendo console I had.
Until the...
DS.
Well...
Yeah.
Until the DS.
So...
Yeah, I didn't really play much of Nintendo.
What about Legend of Zelda?
I only played the Game Boy ones.
I never played the N64 ones.
Even to...
Even now.
Even to this day, I have not played.
Like, Majora's Mask and Ocarina of Time.
Never, never.
You are a gaming hipster.
Truly.
I don't know if it would be trouble.
Because Nintendo, but my favorite N64 games...
Was Paper Mario and Zelda Ocarina Majora Mask.
I want to play them.
I just...
I guess I just never got around to it.
There was a time when I just didn't play a lot of games.
You know?
Like, I played...
What I played...
What I liked to play as a kid.
And then...
I stopped playing games for a long time.
It was really la...
Yeah.
And then...
Now I play games...
Every day.
You should totally play Zelda.
Would it be crazy?
To have somebody's first time ever playing...
In 2025?
Is that a rare experience?
Don't...
I would play the hell out of...
Oracle of Ages and Oracle of Seasons.
Oh yeah, that's true.
I guess they're...
Well...
Someone who grew up in that era...
And didn't play them.
I guess you're right.
There are people that haven't played them...
But they're babies!
Those are the children...
You're talking about.
I'm thinking of someone...
Of my...
Status.
My status.
19.
How long have you been 19?
Oh wait, sorry.
I'm...
Wait, no.
That's the...
No, I'm supposed...
That's supposed to be Bella.
I'm 19.
How long have you been 19?
Forever.
No, not 20!
I should have never shown you guys that video.
I actually...
I don't regret showing you guys by audition...
But I felt like it sparked a bunch of weird...
Weird dialogue from people being like...
Imagine if Minta got into a holo instead...
But like then people were coming at me being like...
How...
But...
She would have to replace...
I don't want to replace anybody that's in myth, okay?
I didn't show you guys with that as my intention...
I just wanted to show you guys something that...
I felt was like kind of...
Lost to media, you know?
You don't...
And...
You don't really get to hear people's audition tapes sometimes...
Because, you know...
It's a little like...
If you want to get...
Into the company, you shouldn't...
Show off...
That kind of stuff.
You know what I mean?
So...
I don't...
It...
It sparked a lot of...
Uh...
A lot of...
Um...
Dialogue that I was like...
No!
This is not what I did...
I don't...
I love everybody who is in myth...
And I wouldn't want to...
Replace any of them...
And I...
Understand entirely why I did not get in...
And I'm okay with that...
Uh...
A lot of weird hypotheticals...
Yeah...
It made me a little uncomfortable...
Not gonna lie...
Because...
Yeah...
I don't know...
Uh...
Yeah...
It's treated as...
Minto from an alternate timeline...
And extended Minto verse...
Yeah...
Uh...
I didn't play the Switch remake, but I did like Link's Awakening.
We're happy we're in the Minto world line.
Yeah, I am.
I'm happy to be here.
As Minto.
It is all good.
The path and all that brought you here now is also part of what made you you.
Yeah, exactly.
You sounded so pure in the video.
Glad you let your inner freak take over.
I don't know.
I don't know why I did such like a...
Like a...
Hello, my name is Mint Panda.
Like it was so breathy.
It sounded like a Disney princess.
I don't know how... I don't think I would be able to keep that up for so...
But I also... You know, it also was like...
My mic and everything too.
My name is Mint Panda.
I am forever.
I don't know.
I don't know why.
But you know...
Lots of people's voices change...
As they stream, I think.
I just woke up and you're playing Kirby's Dream Land.
Very nice to me though.
I don't make it obvious, but I'm a big Kirby fan.
I couldn't tell.
Actually, I just...
I just finished Kirby's Dream Land.
But thank you for the third day.
Never mind Hollow, your vids and the wisps love you.
And I am happy...
Where I am right now.
I do not plan on going anywhere.
I can say that... I can make that very clear.
You're still a princess, but with freaky thoughts.
Hehehe.
Guilty.
Also, I must point out that the mic quality in that video was surprisingly good.
I...
I thought so too!
Listening to it, I was like, what mic did I use?
I have no idea.
It was really good and all.
Interesting.
I think that they...
I think...
They think you wouldn't have had such a bad time in Hollow instead of...
In Heaven.
Maybe.
I don't...
Um...
Uh...
I have to...
To put it...
Not to go too deep into it or anything.
I...
You know...
Accept the choice I made.
I don't regret it because I was able to learn a lot.
So...
And all I can do is move forward.
Keep on keeping on.
Yeah, yeah.
Have you played Ghost Babble?
On the Game Boy.
I did not play it on the Game Boy, but I did stream it.
I did stream...
Ghost Bubble.
Yeah, yeah.
So you can find the VOD on my channel.
If Minto was a Kirby character, she would be Waddle Dee.
Who's Waddle Dee?
Oh, he's so cute.
Why am I Waddle Dee?
I had a dream you banned me from your membership, then announce your marriage of members.
Why me?
I felt horrible.
Take responsibility to...
Shut up.
Don't...
Oh my gosh.
Have you ever done that?
Where you like have a dream about somebody, but in the dream they piss you off?
And then you wake up and you're actually mad at that person?
So...
Why...
Why are we so stupid as a society?
It's a shame Mint didn't pass the Three Stooges audition.
I think she'd be Curly Howard.
Uh, joke's on you.
I'm their producer.
I think that's a girl thing.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I think that's a thing people do.
Women thing!
That's a female thing.
Why is it getting worse and worse?
Um, that's what girls do.
Um, that's a...
That's what women do.
Um, that's a female thing.
It's just getting more and more degrading.
Oh, dude's here.
I'm...
I'm one of the dudes.
Okay.
Anyway.
Um, thank you guys for carving again.
Do an epic watch along.
Oh, like the epic musical.
Maybe.
Maybe, maybe.
My brother beat the shit out of me in a dream.
And when I woke up, I told him how sick it was.
That's a good relationship.
Thank you for streaming with everybody!
I'm gonna head out.
And, um...
Yeah, this is a lot of fun.
This is so silly.
Um, I'm gonna raid Kiwawa.
She's playing Blueprints and I want to go watch.
So, otumito everybody!
Thank you!
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
And I will see you...
When I see you...
Next!
Enjoy the rest of your day, Mito.
Thank you!
You as well.
Enjoy...
I will see you guys on Sunday.
Um...
It's my rest day.
So...
Enjoy the rest of your weekend.
And I will see you guys...
When I...
See you...
Next!
Bye-bye!
Otumito!
Thank you so much, everybody!
Thanks for your help, too.
With, uh...
With some of these...
Some of these guys.
Otumito!
Bye-bye!